The joe rogan experience.
Okay.
Here's a serious question.
Is there a guy that has ever existed that has a full suit of armor in his house
that isn't a douchebag?
Nope.
Well,
I mean,
comic book collector guys aren't really Douche bags.
You know,
they like that shit.
like they have like,
they have like a real suit of armor in their house.
I've almost bought it an armored helmet the other day.
I saw helmets.
Helmets are kind of dope.
Yeah,
I almost bought one of those.
I could see it.
I would say last case I would say,
uh,
the same could be said about those dives.
Store a Indians.
Oh,
cigar store Indian
or the black jockeys that you put on your lawn.
Oh fuck.
How about people who have like little gremlins and shit on there?
The elves,
you know,
what do they call him?
My Step Mama has it.
He East on her front porch today.
If it starts to rain,
she puts a raincoat on it.
And then if it's like Halloween,
she dresses up in a low cost and it's like this,
this big ceramic geese.
And then I,
I was,
I always make fun of it.
And then somebody came broke it recently and she was so sad about it.
So now she has all these stupid geese outfits and she can't find another one of
them.
So see,
are you kidding me?
No.
Some geese.
What happened today?
It was the worst day of my life.
Someone cracked my ceramic bed.
How you had that one than I leave.
It makes me so happy.
I come home.
I you see my ceramic duck.
I got him into Toronto world fairy 62 it's acts.
They don't make 'em or that much anymore.
He's beauty foe.
He defined my God.
I swear you still look at me.
He was my friend.
I know that sounds retarded.
I don't care.
He was my friend
ever since he left.
Ever since Jimmy left,
he's gone.
Oh,
ever since he's gone.
A house is haunted.
Ever since he's gone.
I feel a little crazy.
I can't sleep at night cause I feel like I failed him and he's going to kill me
in my sleep.
I should have,
I should have gotten him a coat of armor.
It was my little Charlie.
I had a name for forum,
Charlie the duck,
and now he's dead.
I had illustrated books I made about him over the years.
He's going to come back and kill those punks that broke them.
Those fucking punks.
Stephen King movie about a fucking evil ceramic duck.
That's some good.
Some kids break.
It goes out and cuts their throat and their sleep.
Yeah.
Just imagine that you're waking up and a giant ceramic doc.
I just cutting your throat.
Yeah.